[Applause]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions it's the ramsy show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create amazing
relationships I'm George camell joined
by Dr John delone bestselling author of
building a non-anxious life uh I guess
I'm an aspiring bestselling author John
I just pre-launched a book and I hope
that it's successful as yours it's
called Breaking Free from broke it's on
pre-sale right now at ramsy
solutions.com store work hard George
aspiring may you accomplish all of your
dreams but we're both YouTubers so we
succeeded in that regard if you're
crushing me ontu that's success well
let's uh let's take some calls the
number is 8825
5225 will help you take the right next
step with your money your mental health
your relationships whatever it is we
will give you our advice that is a
guarantee all right let's start with
Jessica in Boston what's going on
Jessica hi so I wondering how uh my
husband and I have we're a family of
five we have three kids five and under
we both work we we make a very good
living north of 300K a year which almost
50 of it is taxfree um because my
husband receives VA disability pay um
monthly but we are we've had several
crisis crisises I guess come up the past
two years um and we were debt-free but
now we've due to the unexpected
occurrences um we're now living beyond
our means paycheck to paycheck have no
savings and you know um our emotional
our physical health is taking a toll our
marriage is taking a toll um and we we
want to stop living paycheck to paycheck
how do we get out of this
um and how can we repair the
relationship along the
way I'm sorry to hear what you're going
through yeah what happened what were the
crises yeah so we um the height of the
real estate market right we we sold our
first house you know this is our
opportunity to get debt free we were
probably I want to say between 50 to
65,000 in debt uh at the height of the
market in 2021 we sold our first home uh
walked away scotf free um paid off the
entirety of our debt um and then I got
pregnant with our third child I was only
six months postpartum um and I was
actually struggling with postpartum
depression in in the inum um I had we
had major complications I was in
pre-term labor for almost three months
um and I am the bread winner between me
and him um very high- pressured you know
uh software uh sales technology sales I
should say um job and which forced me to
uh need to take a a medical leave of
absence due to my postpartum getting so
bad um it was literally for the safety
of myself and my family that I had to
take a medical leave and the day I
returned to work I was laid off um in
turn we literally two weeks yeah it was
bad so two I want to say a month prior
to me going back to work uh we had just
closed on a new home uh our forever home
and the bills piled up quick so how much
dead are you in
now it's
probably I want to say between 22 to
25,000 total and what kind of
debt yeah so it's unsecured loan debt
credit card debt
um should I include the car or no yes
that's Deb isn't it okay then it goes up
from there so I would tck on a total an
additional 60 an addition so you're
probably $85,000 in Consumer Debt are
you are you back to working now I am I
am I found a new job fairly soon within
a month um and I am working are you
still making 300,000 take some time to
build the pipeline again so okay what
what what's your husband do yeah he
works um for the government
um and he was a marine and now he works
for the government as a cfy inspector
okay for OSHA so I'm gonna let George
talk you through this this debt
situation but I want to say a couple
things okay okay the first thing is I'm
really really glad you're still
here thank you appreciate that making
that call when you're holding a baby is
one of the scariest calls you can make
right it's is yeah cuz there's that
demons telling you that um they're going
to take your baby away people are going
to say you're crazy and they're going to
lock you up and I'm so so proud of you
for doing that that's
hard and we're good now
right for the most most of the time I
still have moments yes there you go um
let me ask you this way you're always
GNA be around here
right yes for sure good um the second
thing is if you haven't already there's
going to come a moment when yall are
going to have to and the quicker you get
here the quicker you can begin to do the
walk the path that Jordan's going to lay
out for you you're going to have to make
peace with grieve the crap out of but
make peace with here's the life we had
and now here's the one we're in right
now okay the more you try to quote
unquote get back to what we had the more
you're going to make yourself nuts cuz
you're just going to run in a
circle you're going to be dragging what
used to
right so we used to have $60,000 cars we
don't anymore we're a Camry family now
we used to have a humongous house and we
had our forever house it's not our
forever house anymore you and me are
forever husband but the house isn't and
that's okay okay and we used to make 300
Grand now we don't and maybe one day we
will again but that's not the world
we're in right now and so when you make
peace existentially with those moments
then remember we had Alexis yeah but now
we got now we got a Corolla and it gets
us where we need to go and you got a
bunch of dope Marine tattoos but you're
going to look awesome smoking hot
getting out of a Camry that's just the
world we have now right yeah and it's
not less than it's just different it's
different and it'll be back it'll be
back you're a you're a hustler your
husband's a brilliant guy I mean you'll
be back but let's make peace with that
new world right and that new world is
Awesome by the way it's top 1% of planet
Earth it's a great world just we got to
let go of what used to be used to be
awesome and then we got laid off and it
sucks and here we are now now it's
awesome again just a different kind of
Awesome
okay so Jessica this is going to start
with some simple math but it's going to
end with some sacrifice and behavior
change you ready for it absolutely mind
is is your husband on board too this is
an important factor he knows how you
feel about all this okay we're going to
get you to Solid Ground and I'll give
you some options it'll be a Choose Your
Own Adventure my guess is your take-home
pay is somewhere around 15 grand a
month
uh yes okay correct so let's look at
what our expenses are what do we need to
keep the household running and you're
going to do that with a budget I'm going
to gift it to you it's called every
dollar I'm going to give you the premium
version it's going to have paycheck
planning connect to your bank account
all the good stuff your homework is to
list out every single expense you have
as a family and ruthlessly cut out the
stuff that doesn't matter that you don't
need right now you got that okay give me
a rough estimate of what that would add
up to five
grand for cutting out or the the total
expenses that would keep the house
running food shelter utilities
Transportation all that
probably 12 12
Grand yep that with our Nanny included
Child Care
included both of us okay this is where
remember those sacrifices I mentioned
Jessica this is where we might have to
figure out how to get that 12 Grand down
to five so we have 10,000 to throw at
the debt and we can be done in 8 months
that might mean selling the cars if you
can't make those sacrific letting the NY
go for a season this is not going to be
fun but your life on the other side is
going to be way better for it so hang on
the line will'll GI you every dollar we
are wishing you the
[Music]
best hey folks you know that sinking
feeling when you make an offer on a
house you love and then you hear there's
another offer you need the Churchill
Mortgage home buyer Edge super fast
pre-approval and a secured interest rate
plus A5 $5,000 seller guarantee gives
your offer the best chance of being
accepted the home buyer Edge from
Churchill gives you an advantage over
those other guys go to Churchill
mortgage.com today to learn
[Music]
more
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George camel joined by Dr John deloney
we're taking your questions atlea 825
5225 you jump in we'll talk about your
relationships your mental Wellness your
financial Wellness all of it right here
on the Ramsey show our question of the
day is brought to you by neighborly your
hub for Home Services with 19 home
service providers Nationwide the network
of local service pros on neighbor.com
can help with just about anything you
need done in and around your home visit
neighbor.com Ramsey to find out more all
right today's question comes from Leanne
in Virginia Leanne writes I've been
hearing that the US dollar may be
Obsolete and so-called experts advising
to do something with money sitting in
various large Banks like Wells Fargo
Bank of America Etc since the market has
been all over the place and the CD rates
have been up we stockpiled a couple
hundred, in Wells Fargo but now after
seeing these alerts we are a bit
concerned what are your thoughts on the
US dollar becoming devalued or
obsolete wow a lot going on here John a
lot going on here all right I'm going to
let you talk about the investing
strategy George but here's my two cents
and you can do with it what you will the
US dollar is how the world does business
right and um I had one a friend of mine
she was a a legal scholar who said the
world
spins planet Earth spins on one sentence
the United States will pay its bill in
US dollars right um pay its bills that's
why things like government shutdowns and
letting the debt cealing not not dealing
with this long-term issue will be an
explosion of catastrophic events if we
don't get this debt under control
nationally and we don't continue to
figure out ways to pay P our bills
and if you owe 30 something trillion
dollars it makes the whole world nervous
and if you just print and invent money
it makes the whole world nervous and
other people can't divorce themselves
from you other countries can't if they
have to pay their bills in your money
right they can't devalue your currency
because then they're devaluing the
amount of money they owe you or you owe
them if there's debt right so there's
been the conversation with Brazil and
Russia and China like the brick is the
big new thing bricks I think it is which
is we're going to start you we're going
to create an alternative world currency
that's not the US dollar not tied to us
and then everyone
goes it's all coming down so here's what
I can tell you I can tell you that if
the US dollar does not continue to be
the world currency and Wells Fargo Bank
of America and fill in- the blank all
fail any amount of things that you think
you have done to prep for that
moment you have not done it will be a
drastically different planet okay the
world will be different at that moment
so I have t like this like every other
it's all G move all your money to Gold
start buying coffee and burying bullets
and silver coins in the ground and buy a
bunch of uh beanie babies and what like
whatever the thing of the day is I
always like to look on the other side of
it and ask myself will the world be
the same like this world I'm preparing
for will it be the same on the other
side of this the answer would be no it'
be a radically different world that we
are all going to have to adjust to to
when we get there so what does that mean
that means I'm going to go throughout my
regular day not trying to time the
meteorite that's going to hit us one day
I'm going to do the next right thing and
the next right thing is given the
information I have in front of me the
world currency is a US dollar and forget
the world currency my country that I
live in uses the US dollar that's what
I'm going to put in the bank and I'm
going to invest it for long term and I'm
going to pay off my debts and I'm going
to next right thing next right thing
next right thing I'm just not going to
get on YouTube and listen to the just
absolute driil that is coming out of
some of the news stations out there who
have no vested interest in information
quality information truth they have in
vested interest their publicly traded
companies they have a vested interest in
one thing clicks your attention so they
can sell ads they're not they're not in
they're not incentivized to give you
correct information and so they're
incentivized to get your attention how I
get your attention it's all coming down
right that's one way right and then you
go what's coming down the dollar well if
John if you upload a video and it's like
guys the dollar is fine everyone just go
to work and love your families it's
going to get zero views nobody wants to
watch that it's not exciting and is
there some challenges are you freaking
kidding me we ow
trillion we have people in Washington
just throwing crayons at each other in a
sandbox like you're dumb no you're dumb
and then I mean it's just it's Madness
so if I am a trading partner with the US
would I be concerned about the absolute
Insanity I see everywhere yep I would no
question about it um should the average
citizen who has a mortgage and a car
payment and some credit card debt be
trying to think through a strategy for
what happens when the dollar goes away
no I would not spend my time doing that
I think there's a ton of hurdles between
the US dollar going away and brick or
whatever these things kicking out
there's there's a lot of strategies I
mean a lot of hurdles in between now and
then the biggest thing we can all do is
take care of our our homes take care of
our personal finances and vote people
who will do what's right and that's
that's the game we that's that's what we
can do that's the game that was a good
intellectual take John mine was not that
smart what do we do I just underline
things that I thought were funny in this
question like so-called experts are
advising me to do something uh so no I'm
not going to trust the socalled experts
out there who are using fear to get your
clicks and I also wouldn't stockpile
hundreds of thousands of dollars in a
bank account because your biggest
problem there is not devaluation it's
inflation eating away at your money
which is very real that part is real and
so I would be investing that money
anything beyond your emergency fund and
your current savings goals invest it in
the long term I still believe in the US
economy and some amazing companies that
are innovating that will cause you know
the economy to rise and the GDP to grow
so I have faith in that and it's all I
you know at the end of the day I can't
control any of it John so I'm just going
to the best thing you can do is be debt
free and have pile of money in the bank
and be investing for the future that's
it otherwise I'm not worried about the
dollar becoming obsolete anytime soon
because I got to pay bills John with
dollars I do think the what you said
earlier is something I wish everyone
would double down and triple down and
quadruple down on which is a great
inflation hedge don't owe anybody any
money a great um gu just got laid off
hedge don't owe anybody any money a
great anxiety mental health challeng
don't owe anybody any money and if more
people would default to as for me in my
house I'm going to take care of that and
I'm going to work seven jobs I'm going
to work 15 jobs I'm going to get rid of
the nanny like the last call I'm going
to get rid of the cars I'm we're going
to drive cor it's like we're going to
make this thing work because so many of
the things on the what can I control and
not control can any of us individually
control whether the US dollar becomes
obsolete no absolutely not there's
nothing we can
do can I control that I don't owe
anybody money and if one day a foreign
currency calls and says I call your note
and I'm like I don't owe you anything
they'll be like okay I'll go to your
neighbor right exactly so I think the
most important thing almost every one of
us can do right now is not owe anybody
any money and work like bloody hell to
get there yeah the that's an interesting
take if you're truly worried about what
could happen with the economy then why
are you owing Ford Motor Company a giant
check every month for that car you must
drive why do you make a payment to to to
Visa it just doesn't care if you truly
and it sounds like this question they
have a BN a bunch of money that probably
don't aren't carrying debt but it's one
of the best things you can do to sleep
better at night because when it all
comes down the lenders are still going
to want their payment and they will do
whatever it takes to get it they will
take you to court in the midst of a
pandemic they'll do whatever it takes
and so the best thing you can do is just
live a debt-free life and turn off the
headlines if you're starting to spin out
of control and John I know there's a lot
of people out there who genuinely want
to they want to stay in touch with
what's going on in the world but what is
the balance there between going all
right all the headlines are telling me
it's all coming down my real life says I
love my family and I like my job and I'm
just going to go to work and go home
this it's just become like an old Trope
right which uh I control I control and
so when I hear something going
on um like this
I mean what can I do what can I do about
what can I literally do about this I
know I'm going to lose money due to
inflation if I put the money under my
bed I know that real estate usually has
a good return over time but I'm not
going to borrow money to do it so I'm
going to put in a high yield savings
account I'm going to invest my money and
on a long-term strategy and that's how
we're going to roll and number one I'm
not going to owe anybody money and we'll
deal with this as this as this rolls out
it's that simple and John you lay out
six daily choices we can make in your
new book building a non-anxious life
which I highly recommend for lyan in
Virginia it actually might help more
than anything and George can turn
anything into a sales pitch that was
impress that's what I do America this is
the Ramsey
[Music]
Show hey if you're in over your head
with student loans and tired of getting
calls from collection agencies if
private student loan debt is taking away
your financial piece and you don't see
any way out you need why refi they're
not a debt settlement company and
they're not connected to a bank why refi
refinances defaulted private student
loans that other places won't touch and
gives you a custom loan built for you
based on your ability to pay so when you
refinance your private student loan debt
with Y refi you'll have a payment you
can afford with a low fixed interest
rate you couldn't get anywhere else to
help you stick to your budget and work
the debt snowball and you can save
thousands of dollar to learn more about
this custom refinancing option and a
lumpsum payoff option you could qualify
for after 24 months call
8442 Ramsey or go to Y re
i.com
[Music]
Ramsey welcome back to to the ramsy show
I'm George camel joined by Dr John
deloney it's a free call atle 8825 5225
you jump in we'll talk about money
mental health relationships and whatever
is on your mind quick reminder for you
all listening the ramsy Christmas Cash
giveaway is here and you could win one
of our $500 weekly prizes or a grand
prize of $5,000 and there is no joy
greater than giving away Dave Ramsey's
money let me tell you right now so you
can enter every single day at ramsy
solutions.com
SLG giveaway to increase your chances of
winning and while you're there we've
also got the $12 sale happening where
you can get lots of great meaningful
gifts at a great deal bestselling books
like The Total Money Makeover baby steps
Millionaires and own your past change
your future and we've got some of Dr
John delon's questions for humans
conversation cards for as low as 10
bucks right now and we've got the
Christmas edition it's back and these
sold out last year so be quick be nimble
shop the sale at ramsy solutions.com
sstore and while you're there we've got
a lot of new stuff Rachel Cruz has a new
kids book my book Breaking Free from
broke is on pre-sale we've got the 2024
gold planner something for everyone on
your list would you consider yourself
quick and Nimble I am actually it's the
one thing I am good at as a small person
I disagree I appreciate that I'll outrun
you any day John you're a small person
but you're not quick or Nimble on that
note Chris and Albany is waiting with
baited breath for our answer to this
question what's going on Chris hey
George Dr Don thank you so much for
having me on the show sure what's up can
we help so I guess one of the things
notice when trying to get on a budget
and one of the things that's kind of
like uh hampering things I should say is
the constant bombardment I'm getting of
emails marketing emails seems like every
time I check my email like 99 out of 100
of them or something trying to get me to
spend money so I was just wondering if
you guys have any tips strategies or
anything to kind of combat this and to
stay on track with the budget what does
it have to do with your
budget well just making sure that we
don't spend extra money more you know
that temptation to spend money from the
mar from the continent uh emails and
trying to get a you know trying to have
you to spend so if I gave you a really
sophisticated answer which was uh just
don't what's your push back to that um
other than then I don't have much push
back and just uh I didn't know if it was
something that like your audience or
anybody might have had anybody has
issues with maybe just trying to like
combat that yeah there's a there's a
simple and effective way to do this and
I talk about this in Financial Peace
University John and I tag team a lesson
on why spending and I talk about this
tiny thing at the bottom of that email
there's this tiny link it's an invisible
font about size you know point4 and if
you click it it'll say sorry to see you
go and you say okay bye subscribe and
unsubscribe there's an unsubscribe link
and that gives me it gives me No Greater
Joy than to hit that link on every
single marketing spam email unless it's
a Ramsey email and then I I accept it
with great joy but for real that's all
it takes uh what kind of marketing
emails are you getting and did you sign
up for them are these stores that you
love it's mostly just like because I've
really tried to get on track with my
spending and getting on a budget and I
be honest I really haven't been that
great um so products I've bought in the
past you know whether you've signed up
for a Rewards program or something in
the past and then you're just
consistently getting those emails and it
feels like it's Non-Stop and and also
I'm not sure like is my email also been
sold to other companies as
well and I think I think it's so much
and I get the unsubscribed thing I've
done that it just it feels like just
there's so much it's just very
overwhelming at time I don't even open
them though what's underneath this
there's something underneath this I
think it's well I think it's also just
like in the email just like oh I might
there might be important emails that
like I'm not neglecting because
sometimes I'll just won't even look at
them but then I may have missed an email
as a result or something give me an
example what's a store that you might be
tempted to spend at um I don't know
maybe it could have been anything from I
I'll throw one out there maybe it's
Amazon maybe it's another company where
I bought clothing things like that all
right so if you were if you were
struggling with
alcohol one of the things I would tell
you if you and I were sitting down and
you had wept and I had heard your story
I would tell you you have to agree today
you're not going back into a bar
period and then you would probably say
well that's where my friends are that's
right on the way home from work that's
my routine that's where my community
it's to my laughs are it's where I get
um connection and I would say and it's
killing you you cannot go back into a
bar and you'd have to figure out another
way home you'd have to figure out other
people but you'd have to figure out
another way to deal with that thing
inside of you that you are trying to
wallpaper over with purchases and
purchases and fomo and what if what if
this is an important email what if it's
not and so here's my challenge to you
delete your email
account just delete it there's 700
Services email Services there's Google
and Y is Yahoo still a thing there's I'm
sure hot mail still exist Does it people
have it I don't know why I have the I
have an mail address yes proton mail
there there's there there's there's
stuff all over the place delete your
email account just delete it and if
there's three or four people that you
want to have your thing just send them a
note that say Hey this is my new email
address just clean slate it and that
would tell me I'm that you are serious
about dealing with this part of your
life that is out of
control CU dude I get emails from some
of the coolest companies and I go
through their stuff and I am like I want
this I would love to get this it' be so
rad I have that and I just
don't or I wait 60 days and then I do or
I ask my wife and she's like really okay
but okay and then I just don't because
she's
right and Chris you mentioned you
mentioned the budget at the top of this
and the budget is going to dictate your
spending and so you're the boss of the
budget but when the budget's done it's
the boss of you so if you have a $200
shopping line item then you have
permission to spend $200 on shopping and
it may be stuff that you that just Chris
wants if he's out a debt and he's in a
good spot it's okay to buy stuff it's
when we do it with the wrong motive when
it's not in the budget when it's not the
right time when we haven't really done
the research it was just impulsive or
emotional that's when it gets out of
hand and it feels like that's what
you're getting at is you you can you're
self aware enough to know you have the
tendency to go
there yep just hear me and George say I
don't I don't fully get the link between
your
budget
and these emails I think it's before I
had a lack of a budget Dr John and I
think now that I'm trying to get on a
budget get everything set just you're
still I'm still seeing those emails just
to avoid that Temptation don't go off
the budget I guess that's kind of why
I'm trying there you go delete your
email account dude and whenever you uh
sign up for Stuff here's what I do I
have like a Spam marketing account and
that's what I give to all these
companies and then I never open that
inbox because I know what's
coming yes so that may be another way to
go about this if you can't delete your
email account if it's connected to 14
million
things okay I appreciate it thank junk
email account and you send it over but I
I usually go through a tie raade where I
just keep unsubscribing from every
single thing for a week straight and
then I tend to stop getting those emails
it's really nice it's a nice feeling
yeah uh let's hold on hold on this is
important any behavior that you think I
can't stop like I can't control a do
what he did and reach out and talk to
somebody whether it's alcohol whether
it's spending whether it's porography
whatever it is the second thing is look
at the environment that's allowing this
thing to happen and begin to make
environmental changes and that's I'm not
going to go in that bar anymore that is
I'm not going to go back in that house
where this person is abusive anymore
that is really tough if you don't have
any money and you're scared and you're
all alone in a new city I get that or it
might be I'm deleting my email account
like I'm just going to get that serious
about it because this isn't a spending
issue this isn't this is something
beneath that he created a budget and
realized he went with him right he
created a budget
and he realized I've been running from a
long time from something inside of me
and I don't want to deal with it and I
don't want to deal with it and I don't
want to deal with it and that budget
forces you to look in the mirror and say
now what do you actually value dude like
who are you going to be and that's tough
it's tough that's a scary moment when
you look at your bank statement for the
last month or two and you go this
represents who I am as a person Y what I
value my identity who I'm becoming who
I've been man that'll set you straight
you're like that was a lot of Taco Bell
in a month who am I becoming mine is
mostly Thorn supplements but I get what
you're saying that's who John is that's
right a man who values his health that's
a good reminder and John you walk
through three really important questions
in that why spender lesson of Financial
Peace University that our brains are
asking on Ancient technology do I belong
am I safe and does this feel good right
and marketing is trying to get at all of
those it's trying to tap into the fears
and going it's going to feel so good if
you just take this supplement John
you're going to sleep so much or or the
Dollar's going away like the earlier
like the earlier question right like are
you safe right um do you belong hey look
at all the guys like us we're all using
this thing and wearing this thing and I
want to be like those guys because those
are that's the tribe I want to identify
with so yeah always step back and ask
yourself is this something I need or is
this something I'm trying to use as duct
tape over a person I don't like usually
the latter but hey if you want to check
out that lesson it's lesson five of
Financial Peace University John and I
tag team it I cover all the ways
companies go after your money and what
you can do to regain control of it you
can go check it out Ramsey Solutions
[Music]
/pu hey guys it's Rachel Cruz it's open
enrollment season so it's a great time
to explore your health care options for
next year if you feel tied down by your
budget check out Christian Healthcare
Ministries chm is not health insurance
it's a faith based Health cost sharing
Ministry that has helped members take
care of nearly billion in healthcare
costs chm is an affordable alternative
to insurance that gives you the freedom
and empowers you to live out your values
and you can join at any time so find out
more at chministries.org
[Music]
budget
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George camel joined by Dr John deloney
hey if you're a new listener to the show
and you want a deeper dive on the Ramy
baby steps you can go to ramsy
solutions.com and click on the get
started button and we will help you
figure out the next best step for your
financial Journey that's ramseys
solutions.com and click on get started
Heather joins us up next in Baltimore
Heather what's going
on hi I'm calling to figure out next
best steps um my husband and I we've
been married about 20 years about i'
would say 10 years ago we did the
Financial Peace University we were in a
ton of debt and we did that for a while
and then we got distracted and stopped
working on it but happily now even
though we didn't pay attention for a
while we are out of debt other than
house um I have a six month emergency
fund and everything and recently I got
an inheritance um from the passing of my
father um for some extra cash so where
we're at now um we have we bought our
house 15 years ago it's 170ish years old
whoa and my biggest argument is stop
watching HGTV before you buy a house
because it was the stupidest thing we've
ever done so so you thought we're going
to turn this into some Victorian
dream maybe not bad but we just thought
we could do a lot more than we have in
15 years so okay I'm very aware I this
is I even take all the blame because
this is 100% on me this house well he
signed on but um so where we're at now
um my my husband has always always
wanted to build a sizable Workshop um he
has hobbies that are big heavy machinery
and he's slightly hoard hoarder um
that's a good combo really expensive
Machinery plus hoarding not it's
expensive they're just big um so right
now we have about 100 $20,000 or so from
The
Inheritance and he clearly wants to go
forward on the building the workshop
because the plan always was build the
workshop then we would have the re the
space to solve other house problems I
have been here long enough to know that
my house needs too much like our
foundation massive issues like you know
everything is old nothing is
everything's basically going to need
replaced at some point in fact it's
needed replaced so just sell your house
sell your house that's what I'm talk
thinking we should do like it would be
smarter to sell our house and find
another house the area we live in
Maryland is an incredibly High Cost of
Living area just sell your house just
sell your house what could it sell for
as is without you putting all this work
into it um I might be able to get
$20,000 out of what over what we owe
what do you owe 190 and you've lived
there 15 years we bought it at 2007
right when the market crashed so it took
a long time just to get back to what we
owed to sell your house and we didn't
put down so sell your house I I'm I'm
there the other concern I have is that I
really like our mortgage where at now
like I he
was hey Heather sell your house sell
your house I'm on that so I I want to do
that it's just but to buy another house
I'm looking at like 400,000 450 other
houses that I could convince my husband
to move into okay here's another idea I
just thought of it don't sell your house
okay
uhuh
Tada how does that hit
you well that's the other one I'm at but
then I have to spend all the money
either like I I still can't all right I
got a new idea I got a new idea six the
house I have a new idea sell your house
and we're back like here's the deal
there's not a right or wrong here you
have just Twisted yourself up like a
pretzel oh I have yes that was tricky
John what you just did do what you
talked about the anxiety thing my $1,500
a month mortgage doesn't give me anxiety
anymore a new house another $1,000 a
month mortgage on top of that does but
you're forgetting that 1500 is not, 1500
it's going to be 150,000 because of what
you're going to have to do to this place
over the next decade but if you put if
you just got a $100,000 inheritance and
you put $100,000 into that house it will
appreciate for
what um in a high cost of living area
would it would would it double would it
be worth 350 to 400,000
bucks no
because the money that would put into it
is is like the invisible stuff that
still just gets it back from not falling
down anymore okay here's an idea, into
it I'm probably getting close to 300 to
350 maybe okay which which almost
doubles
it well at 200 now but yeah okay what
would it cost to rent somewhere let's
say you sold it you have 140 you keep
saving and saving on top of that what if
for one year you rented while
saving would your husband go for that or
does it crush his dreams not for 5
seconds
why he has stuff problems okay well
let's deal with the stuff problems
problems putting oursel in a terrible
financial position here's what I think
can I tell you can I just say what I
think you tell me if I'm wrong say
you're an idiot and you're wrong I
think your marriage is not as good as
you're letting on and I also think and
maybe maybe your marriage isn't bad you
and your husband are two very different
pages y are great co-managers of your
house your
roommates and you have some other stuff
going
on and this is a big uh marryg go around
that you can get on and go around and
around and contemplate all the reasons
you should stay and all the reasons you
should go and what it allows you to do
is avoid dealing with the scary scary
truth sitting inside your house probably
sitting on your couch right next to you
there could be relevance there
but there could be relevance there
awesome this isn't going anywhere right
all right so if I were to take on
additional mortgage no no no no we're
not doing that my house okay listen to
me back to that what about this what
about taking your husband out for dinner
and saying honey I plan us a
date and sat down and said I'm scared to
death about the trajectory of our
marriage
I want to get you a barn but how you
spend money and your addiction to stuff
scares me and the fact that I'm running
really low some might call it depression
and I'm anxious a lot scares
me I'm scared our house is going to fall
down I'm scared we can't afford to move
I can't breathe in this
house what if you did that I just felt
my shoulders drop just saying that for
you this wouldn't be a new
okay then you have to deal with that
reality and selling your house or not
selling your house is not you and your
husband are going to go with you to your
new house yes you and your husband are
going to go with you when you build a
shop that you can't
afford well that's not
happening because I won't say yes to
that yeah him having this dream workshop
solv zero problems yes so we need to
deal with a Rude problem which number
one
is we are way far away on our values
when it comes to our dreams and vision
financially so we need to align on that
first before we make any
decision and if we can't find alignment
on that it's worth reaching out to a
third party our friends at better help
we need to get to the root of this CU if
he still has his addiction to stuff
we're going to be broke three years from
now regardless of what we do you sound
really close to
resentment it's not resentment what is
it this has been here for long this I I
this is our reality you've resigned I
can't change another person I can choose
to make decisions going forward based on
the reality that exists like or I
obviously could leave but that's not an
option okay um so but I the only thing
that stops me really from trying to buy
a different house
is that then brings on like it just
makes money Tighter and we were a single
income family for a long time for the
last few years we have not been and it's
amazing to not feel stressed about money
anymore MH
I like that so some sometimes when I've
had a house that I just want to get out
of really bad yeah
I sometimes overinflate just how the
house is falling down it's gonna fall
down I promise I'm not no no no I'm just
I'm just saying what I did not what you
do I would go through that list of
questions like the things that you think
have to be done the things that you had
planned to do because of httv back in
the day and then the chip and Joanna
things that would just make make it
amazing like make a list of those
things and put real not imaginary put
real dollar amounts to them just see
what you're talking about because right
now you have no data you have a storm
that just is on on repeat in your mind
and it your body's keep your body's
wearing out because of it um sit down
with real numbers and real stuff and
then see what this looks like I I don't
know another option for you cuz you said
you've had the hard conversation with
your husband and he doesn't he'd rather
have his big toys than have a a wife
that feels loved and safe and so as
George said you're going to have to deal
with a marriage counselor at some point
but I would love for you to sit down and
say okay let's get serious about
answering the questions about this house
let's that's going to allow us to get
serious about what we do next but I'm
telling you right now these imaginary
conversations you're having over and
over and over in the loop and the what
if but then what if and then the what if
you're driving yourself into an early
grave you're worth more than that that
puts this hour of the ramsy show in the
books
[Music]
a
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions it's the ramsy show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create amazing
relationships I'm George camel joined by
the Dr John delone and we are here for
you America the number to call is
5225 Emily's going to kick us off in
Reno Emily welcome to the ramsy show
hi thank you what's going
on so I've been listening to you guys
for a couple months now um and I've
eventually talked to my husband about it
he was a little bit reluctant at first
but now he's on board um we don't have
any credit card debt which is great um
but we do have two truck truck loans and
our house um and what we're thinking
about doing and he's on board with but
we're not sure if it's the right move is
to take what we have in our largest
retirement account and pay off the truck
loans um which are average uh kind of
large um and then that would free up of
course a lot of our income to either put
toward the house or to rebuild the
retirement account which we feel like we
could do fairly quickly um um so I just
wanted to get your guys's opinion and
take on that well first of all I love
that you guys are aligned on wanting to
get out of debt the goal is great the
method is terrible of robbing our
retirement accounts to achieve this uh
so let's talk about what what's left on
these
loans um the larger one is around 37,000
and then the smaller one is a little
over 20 okay and what's your household
income
uh together we make about 150 a year
good okay awesome income so let's look
at it this way if retirement accounts
were not an option to Rob which by the
way if you take a withdrawal against
that you sound young I'm I'm guessing
you're not
60 no but we're not uh we're not super
young he's 43 and I'm 41 so you're
really young according to the government
you are not old enough to be retired
you're not a retired we're young but
yeah that's why we're nervous about you
know that's why I called is because it
sounds like a good idea but I'm a little
nervous about do you know what what it's
going to do to you guys not only with
taxes and penalties but also robbing
from your potential future growth on
that money against a depreciating asset
and then we' thought we thought about
you know because the the company we're
with allows you to like basically take a
loan against
yourself but yeah which we don't to do
which we didn't want to do yeah we
didn't want okay how about this if
you're that desperate to get out of debt
why not sell the
trucks uh well we need them hold on hold
on hold on you need a $40,000 truck for
what you guys are ruthless um because
hold on hold on I I live out in the
country I live on some acreage I do need
a truck I'm an avid Hunter and I have
stuff all over my property and and I I'm
not any better we are Avid Outdoors
people um we have a camper that's bought
and paid for no payments um so we need
the the truck to pull it um and then the
other one is just you know our the
smaller truck was we use my husband uses
drives it all the time um I guess we're
not desperate to pay it off I mean we do
okay you're desperate enough to Rob your
retirement at 30% with interest and
penalties not to mention lost lost
future earnings for a a car that will go
down in value every
year okay well I guess the reason that
got me thinking about that is because I
listen to you guys all the time and I
hear like Dave always talking about like
go scorched like
don't um you know like put everything
into getting debt free so yeah but he
also says never Rob your retirement
account to pay off debt or yeah you
don't go scorched Earth and like
scorched Earth means we're going to
sacrifice and use our future income and
sell everything we can in order to get
out of debt it it can also mean we're
going to sell the trucks to get out of
the that but if that's not an option I I
pinned you into that corner to say well
the other option is let's use this
amazing $150,000 income to pay off
$57,000 in debt yeah but guess what
that's going to take a different kind of
sacrifice that means we're not eating
out it means we're going to pause all
investing as we attack this dead which
that was my next question question um
because we just in the last like year we
really ramped up our um thinking for the
future um so we've always put into our
401ks and retirements but just this last
year we upped our percentage to 8% for
both of us um plus our employer matching
and then we opened a IRA that we put a
couple hundred a month
in uh and what what what is your what is
your APR on your trucks
what's your interest on your truck oh I
think well the the 20 that we got them
in the last couple years when interest
rates have been high was inflation so I
think they're around like 13 nothing
says I'm thinking about our future like
taking out a $337,000 loan at 133%
interest and trying to earn it in a
volatile 10% Market you see what I'm
saying yeah yeah so your math doesn't
even work Emily we're having fun with
you we're not trying to just rag on you
I'm trying to get you to the point
you're willing to go You're right our
our plan is not working trying to invest
while taking on debt while having the
camper debt free but then we need a
$4,000 loan to run the camper we didn't
think this through and so the great news
is this is a very solvable problem so
easy to
solve okay but there's only two
solutions you either sell the trucks or
you pay them off very quickly with
future income by selling stuff getting
on a budget cutting expenses increasing
income that's it no life hacks no
retirement robbing that's it do you guys
what do you think
about um because I know well I think I
know in the baby steps that I read that
um you don't
invest retirement and everything add up
what it would be to pause all retirement
my guess is it's going to be close to a,
bucks a month if not more well and
here's here's why that's important in
your situation yeah you having a paid
for camper and a $40,000 loan against
the the truck that makes the camper
usable and you choosing to pause your
investing while you're quote unquote
getting serious about your future you
will see how insane what you're doing is
because you're going to say there's no
way I want to pause investing we have a
match in everything and then the next
logical question will be what if we sold
this camper and paid this truck off what
if we sold this camper and this truck
and everything in our life changes
literally in a weekend all of it and
then we can breathe and then we can say
what if or how often do we have actually
use this camper what if we used a tent
what if we went to koas what if we built
this thing back up because you said at
the beginning of the call we feel
confident we could just refill our
emergency I mean our retirement really
quick cool just use that same energy and
buy yourself another camper down the
road in a few years if we enter into a
recession there's going to be a lot of
campers on the market you can sell yours
right now while the Go's good and you're
also going to double your investing if
you follow our plan you're going to go
from 8% to 15% of household income
you're going to build ex extreme wealth
by doing that and when you spend cash on
that next camper and that next truck
you're going to spend it differently cuz
it's your own money and you might be
buying a $220,000 truck cuz it hurts too
much to let go of $40,000 in cash that
could be working for you instead of
against you so that was a fun time
beating up on Emily but it's because we
love Emily we want her to win with money
and sometimes that means tough love and
getting rid of crap and
sacrificing
[Music]
well you've all played the telephone
game the first person Whispers a message
to the second person who Whispers it to
the third and so on around the table
until the original message has
completely changed multiply that
confusion by a 100 if you run a business
with different software systems that
don't talk to each other that's why
there's netw site by Oracle in the early
days of Ramsey we were using different
systems for all of our business units we
needed one single source for accurate
data netsuite was the software we used
to optimize and take us to the next
level netsuite gave us the visibility
into all of our numbers so that we could
communicate across departments and plan
ahead better and as we grew it scaled
with us net week worked for ramsy and it
will make a difference for your business
too join the more than 34,000 customers
who trust netsuite to help make them
smarter and make better decisions and
level up their operations to learn more
get a free product tour at netsuite.com
Ramsey that's netsuite.com
[Music]
Ramsey
[Applause]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George camel joined by Dr John deloney
well big news if you missed it we
pre-launched my new book Breaking Free
from broke it's my first book ever I'm
real proud of it and uh you can
pre-order today for only 20 bucks and
get $100 in free bonus items including
instant access to my newest talk from
our smart conference event called show
me the money exclusive access to an
online private event and Q&A the audio
book which will be enhanced and very
exciting the ebook and on top of all of
that you're going to get three months to
every dollar premium to try that out to
live out the principles in this book
this is everything you never learned
about money but wish you did this is how
the debt industry how companies come
after your money how to break free from
broke and how to live out this ramsy
plan that freed me to go from broke to
millionaire many moons ago and so I'm
going to expose all the myths and lies
that we believe from credit cards
student loans credit scores Auto Loans
mortgage traps investing traps you name
it and uh I'll show you the way out I'm
going to show you how to ditch debt and
build wealth and buck this toxic system
and you can get it today at ramsy
solutions.com store and we'll send it to
you in January when the book is out
Mike joins us in Washington DC up next
Mike welcome to the show hey guys thanks
uh hope you're doing well today
absolutely what's going on with you well
I have an 88- year old mother who's
getting ready to run out of money um
like really run out of money but let me
give you a background here uh my dad
passed away 15 years ago and he left her
the 15 acre property that that they were
living in and she stayed there uh the
house is now say neglected certainly
dated need some work it's about 45
minutes away from me and where my
brother lived but in 2020 she had a
little issu she's been having some
medical issues she nearly burned the
house down had some issues like that so
my brother and his wife convinced her to
live in a nearby retirement home and I
wasn't included in that process she
didn't want to move but she agreed and
she's been there since August of 2021
and been paying the mortgage on the
house and she'd been paying for the
retirement home and that's about B rate
of about 10 ,000 a month um I don't know
all of her finances I I I ask her
questions and she gets irritated my
brother's kind of handling that but
without a power of attorney or anything
um I Bas have to steal some mail and and
look at it figure out and what I got
down to is that in her family trust all
the money my dad left and her parents
left her and everything there's about
$3,000 in cash left in that and about uh
maybe 30,000 um in stocks and I think
about 15 in a treking account and that's
it have you not called your brother and
just said what in the world do you do
how does that conversation go uh it
usually goes with I'm working on it um
he wants to make sure the house is
perfect before it sells which it'll
never happen that that's one thing I've
asked you know what's going on with the
finances I'll get back to you oh there's
a plan I I'll tell you but I've never
been told how how dude I'm being honest
like I've got I've got a brother he's
got such he's a person of such
impeccable character this wouldn't this
would never apply
but I would I would be really close if I
were you to in fact not really close I
would probably draft a letter from an
attorney cuz a something sounds fishy
here B I don't care what plan your
brother has your mother's about to lose
everything yeah everything it's it's
it's time to stop waiting for a plan one
of the problems here and I'm sure
something you've probably heard of like
she's come out and said in the past she
likes him better she as a person and
everything else now that aside uh she
every time I ask about something oh I
trust him I I used to take her to the
doctor and IID take her shopping I don't
even get that that anymore so I'm so far
out of the loop um on this because I
think ultimately I'm the realist and I'm
the one who who has to um I'm the one
who tells her what she needs and he's
the one who does what she wants and
that's part of the problem why this
house is sitting on market for it's not
even been on market for two years it
hasn't even been on the market yet in
two years um but yeah
it's do you think he has some kind of
vested interest where he's driving this
wedge between you guys on purpose and he
stands to gain
something no I think he's just pretty
much kind of like just just a dumb dumb
and he has always had issues uh ocv type
issues but also just uh he can't make a
decisions those sorts things he's the
older brother I'm the younger brother
yeah but nobody nobody's that dumb to
where there's $240,000 in an account and
two years later at a burn rate of 10
grand a month there's three everybody
knows this this train stops next
month yeah and it it actually when it
stops it's going to park itself in his
house it's so yeah there's nowhere else
now she says she's gonna get a camper
and take her cat and of course she says
that that's not happening of course of
course so here's the deal it sounds like
two there's two things one is there's
the money aspect of it
but I'm more interested
in you are watching your mom a woman you
love and who loved
you slowly peel away and head in a
direction that you don't believe is
healthy and I think what you've just
played out for us it's not healthy and
you're
heartbroken yeah there there's really
it's kind of the one of the reasons I
call it was kind of a precautionary tale
for others who you know you think you
have a plan her plan was to die and I
know that's a fact she planned to die at
that house and all this would be taken
care of of course of course um and I
think she still counting on that now
like oh it's not gonna be a problem
because I'll be dead and it's gonna go
away what if she lives another decade
well yeah she says she's going to live
to be 100 and then the other hand you
know well do some quick math with her
and show her that she's out of money in
a year I'm I'm more worried that there's
way more money in this trust than your
brother's done something nefarious with
it he's either so in so listen to this
the options here he is so incredibly
incompetent that his incompetence is so
bad his mother's going to end up
homeless or he's had some Financial
incentive to keep you out of the
books well she refinanced this house 10
years ago now she's been in it for 30 so
she would have paid it off um my dad had
sold our old house when they moved out
to this other place so there's 300,000
that was put into it into a $500,000
like it would have been paid off
somebody somewhere about 10 years ago
got her to refinance and about 10 years
ago my brother was $20,000 in debt and
then suddenly bought a house so sure I'm
I'm kind of thinking that's where that
money went but nobody wants to tell me
and that's why she gets irritated and he
won't answer the questions and I think
they refinanced she took the pulled out
the equity here's the deal brother
here's the deal man you
can
wipe your hands of this and grieve like
bloody hell your
mom yeah and your relationship and it
shouldn't be this way and you wish you
were still one of her boys and she has
chosen the other one she's told you I
choose him over you I cannot wrap my
head around how devastating that would
be if my mom did that you know what it's
actually um more than devasta it's
actually a relief okay because now I
know I I know why things are happening
the way they are okay it it might be a
relief in the short
term but you're going to have to grieve
that or the second thing is you get an
attorney and demand financial
accounting and quite honestly you're
gonna have to sue your brother probably
and if she made him the the heir of this
stuff it your suit probably won't even
matter yeah he's the executive but not
the power of attorney who's the power of
attorney nobody she she still retains
everything oh okay well this is
bordering on Elder Financial abuse and
so that makes me think we need to get
some third parties involved to look into
this before we continue to destroy her
life yeah those are the words I was
looking for because that's what I was
thinking but you've kind of I mean I'm
no lawyer but I would contact one
immediately and just explain the
situation and here's what's hard she
might talk to an attorney and say I have
directed my oldest son to do every
single thing I want and when I run out
of money I'm going to move in with him
or I'll move back to to my magic
home both of those are options on the
table for her uhhuh she said so the
bottom line is an 88-year-old woman
should not have $10,000 in expenses
every single
month no especially with a burn rate
with with a Finish Line com tells me her
expenses aren't 10 that money is going
somewhere and it sounds like it's going
partially to your brother so I'm sorry
you're dealing with this Mike this is a
a tangled web of just broken
relationships and financial abuse and uh
I hope you find some resolution even if
it's not the one you're looking for this
is the Ramsey
[Music]
[Applause]
Show
[Music]
[Applause]
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees
everything's backed by their 100%
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free seey blinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverage
visit blinds.com to get up to 45% off
that's blinds.com rules and restrictions
May
[Music]
apply this is the Ramsey Show I'm George
camel joined by Dr John deloney the
number to call is
5225 Chris joins us in Seattle
Washington Chris welcome to the Ramsey
Show hey thanks for taking my call I had
a question I'm I found Dave Leighton
live so I'm following I'm just now
getting started with his baby steps and
I'm on baby step number two um I got
about 8,000 in credit card and about 57
in personal loans um I have a 401k loan
aside those two and I'm trying
everything in mea to go against what
Dave says on the 401K loan um because
it's the interest I'm would receive back
um and it falls in between some of these
loans as in the you know monetary value
so I'm curious if that should be paid
off in that order which is what I'm
thinking again which I'm guessing you
guys will probably say to
do because of the interest I'm just
curious on your guys's I don't know at
what point did you think this is about
the
interest because it seems like there was
a series of decisions made that is left
you in a place where you're feeling
stressed out and anxious overwhelmed by
a pile of debt so I'm far less concerned
about the interest and more concerned
about how do we get Chris back to some
Financial Foundation where he doesn't
owe anyone anything right so what what's
the balance of the 401K
loan it started at six it's about 5,000
now okay and what other debt do you have
you have the credit card personal loans
401k
loan and and that's and I have a
deficiency balance from a vehicle so
I'll give a this little backstory I
found Dave a few months ago and I'm got
on this thing I stopped all 41k
investment which was really hard for me
because of the the match um but you took
a loan against your
right so we can't get too excited about
the free money when we just robbed
ourselves of it right and so I I turn I
got rid of a vehicle that was very
expensive you already did the voluntary
repo it's done okay what's the
deficiency balance on that 33 and some
change good God was it an airplane car
what was
it it was a it was a brand new diesel
truck okay what are you driving
now uh it's a little Isuzu car beater
paid for um worth about 1500 yeah good
okay hey hold on hold on how old are you
Chris real quick George then get back
how old are you Chris I'm 37 all right I
keep hearing some shame in your voice
brother let it let it ride I'm freaking
proud of
you well I'm shamed or I'm embarrassed
because of the amount of money I do make
yeah hold on hold on dude we all learn
we all
learn and George and I talk to
six-figure broke people all the time and
we talk to millionaire teachers all the
time so dude you are not dumb you're not
an idiot you're clearly good at what you
do professionally you probably just did
what everyone in your life told you to
do what the next right smart move was so
stop with the shame man I'm proud of you
you found listen you've lived for this
many years thinking this was the path
and you now have a new path
cool I'm going to hold my head up high
I'm going to take this New Path I'm not
going to spend my time on this new path
just beating myself up for being on the
old path we're on the new one now man we
don't hit each other on this path we
just solve problems okay that's number
one number
two here's this the key that I want you
to digest before you go any further on
this plan because it's going to hold you
up if you don't the way you've done it
for 37 years hasn't worked will you try
something
new right yes and that was sort of my
thinking when I quit the 401K um you
know
investing it was really hard for me
because I'm like that money all I could
see was that money but um but it hasn't
worked same with when you when you
approach George with the with the
interest rate in it that model hasn't
worked not just for you for most of
America doesn't work doesn't work and
George has the keys to your freedom
right here but I want you to change your
psychology you you you're done right
you're on A New Path sweet we're so so
glad that you're in this cult with us
and the way you did it the old way it
didn't work let's say we're going to do
a new one all in is that cool yep all
right all right what's your total
monthly payments on all of this
debt uh it's
[Applause]
about about
2,000 Okay now what's your
income it's it'll be 150 this year but
it's going to drop to 135 next year
because they want us to have a more work
life balance so they're cutting some
overtime okay well you can go pick up a
side hous hole and keep it at 150 or
even higher right sounds like you just
freed up some time that is with my that
is with my side hustle my base salary is
127 and then I about 10 11,000 on the
side hustle great um and I take a day
for myself um so I'm working about two
days I work uh Monday through uh
Thursday in my engineering gig and then
Friday I um Saturday I take for myself
and then Sunday or Friday and Saturday I
work and then I take Sunday for myself
what's your take-home pay every month
without investing what's your take-home
pay going to be on average it's going to
be probably about 7 okay so your goal is
to figure out how much Gap and margin we
can create between your expenses which
is going to be food utility shelter
transportation and those debt payments
everything else we're going scor
scorched Earth for a while because
making 150 how quickly can you pay off
this $113,000 in debt so you get really
intense about it how many years is it
going to take I estimated two and a half
years I'm saying two or less if you're
following our plan 18 months
Max okay so now think about this I guess
I just haven't been able to see the
numbers um that's what I want you to see
is the numbers see what your life looks
like two years from now when you freed
up $2,000 worth of payments and you have
a fully funded emergency fund you never
have to turn to a lender again you never
have to feel feel the shame of one of
these money mistakes again you just get
to walk in Freedom making 150 Grand with
no payments nobody's going to tell you
what to do nobody's going to demand
payment from you at the end of the month
are you a
homeowner I am what's left on the
mortgage 3:30 and you're living
alone uh yes okay I want you to start
dreaming about what is what what does
Chris look like 10 years from now when
he's got a paid four house making 50
probably more 10 years from now with no
payments in the world including no
mortgage think about that and then let's
reverse engineer it to where we make
decisions today that get us there and
one of those decisions is pausing
investing another one of those decisions
is screw the interest rate I'm going to
go smallest to largest cuz I make
$150,000 so who freaking cares these
loans are going to get knocked out so
quickly and then you're going to be
facing down the barrel the that car loan
the deficiency balance and then we're on
to the personal loan of 57,000 and 24
months from now you're going to call us
back and do your dead free
scream all right that's it that's your
one goal but we can't sit here and look
at the interest rates and math anymore
we've got to focus on Behavior
change right we can argue about math
once your debt free that'll be a fun a
more fun time for us at least when we
get to celebrate with you too so if you
make it 150 or take your your your gross
is about 125 where is the other 5,500
bucks a month going that you only bring
home seven so my mortgage is right at
3,000 with all the expenses okay um and
then uh fuel
um
uh you're talking you're talking you
have you have 7,000 left after you pay
all your bills and everything no no I
take 7,000 home so three 3,000 anywhere
from three to 3200 is uh monthly
expenses for the
house uh and then I have you know my
phone bill my sure other but John's
saying hey you're grossing 12 you're
taking home seven 5,000 can't be going
to taxes every month well a lot of it
was going into
401ks so that's going to you freed up
that money now you pause so you might be
taking home eight or n Grand yeah be
about eight and a half or
nine right and so next year it's going
to drop to my base salary Dro down to
127 and then I'll have about 10,000 um
take home or not take home but in other
side hustles Okay cool so we're still
going to we're still working with nine
and you have 2,000 off the top that you
have to pay so now you're done to seven
and then you got 3,000 bucks so I
actually I take that back I pay 3,000
amongst all those all those loans and
stuff 3,000 what I
PID sweet we're going to start knocking
them out smallest to
largest I'm going to help you out with
that Chris hang on the line we're going
to send you every dollar premium you're
going to make a list income minus
expenses need need to equal zero you
give every dollar a job create as much
Marin as you can to throw it that
smallest debt and you're going to feel
the momentum in no time man thanks for
the call this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
this is the ramsy show I'm George
Campell joined by Dr John delone you can
call us at
5225 John is with us in Boston
Massachusetts John welcome to the show
hi guys how are you doing today doing
good what's
up so basically uh I'm 37 married uh I
got three kids one of our two reliable
Vehicles has started acting up so I
started looking at placing it does that
make it does that make it the unreliable
one uh I mean that's hard to say it's
like it's only 5-year-old vehicle right
it it should not be in this situation
but it is uh it's a truck and my
transmission is essentially blown um so
I can limp around town in it but we're
talking like a $7,000 repair um right
now I owe 11,000 on the truck it's worth
about 30 so like the numbers make sense
to repair it but it's also a 5-year old
truck with 100,000 miles on it with this
being a fairly significant repair I
started looking at buying like a new car
right and that's like what should I
spend
financially that's how I got you know to
your site and started you know consuming
this content but now I'm like this
doesn't seem like borrowing 50 Grand
makes sense right now so you thought the
solution was let me borrow more money to
get out of this
pickle yeah okay we've all been there
the good thing is at least the truck is
not upside down right like equity in it
now you're saying it's worth 30k if you
fix the
transmission so I mean I've kind of like
been slippering around to different
dealerships and I feel like I can get
away with trading don't be that guy
don't be that guy cuz a single mom's
getting up in that car do that be a
person of Integrity dude not for a
depreciating
asset fair enough it just sucks it how
much money do you
have like what do you mean in my bank
account
yeah 260k in my savings account
what you're my hero dude what are you
doing def mismanaging finances for sure
no doubt about that what other debt do
you have how much debt do you have
yeah uh so you know my wife has a
minivan we owe about 15K on that 15
morgage with 15
okay so total car is 26k and beyond that
we have nothing we have a mortgage that
we pay we ow 304,000 no credit cards no
student loans or
anything uh no we do use our credit card
for like all of our expenses but we
haven't paid interest ever so what do
you do for a
living uh like a people manager with a
pharmaceutical company ah okay cool
what's the household
income uh 265 in that range okay base
base so well the solution here is simple
if you want to keep the truck let's just
fix the transmission and drive it but
we're also paying off these car loans
today okay I mean that's sort of what I
had heard from like now I'm taking in
the content is like pay these off yeah
the only thing I was wondering is since
there's such a low percentage I was
waiting for that I was like I bet this
guy's got a low interest rate he's
making 5% of his savings account and
he's like bro I'm making the spread
right yeah yeah well that's the science
right like that's the math in it I
learned it in a Harvard Bar you know
what else math tells us to do stay out
of debt because when we have payments
going out it lowers our money that we
get to keep and it also causes us to buy
things that we otherwise wouldn't have
purchased we would have SP spent less
money if we had used our own money you
know what I
mean oh I'm feeling that right now
especially when I'm like looking at
interest rates and talking about taking
this cash out of my savings yeah it's
just it's just not wor BMW to a a beater
you know you're too smart you're too
successful and you have too much money
to be playing the spread
game and one thing you've never
experienced and here's here's this my
it's a cool you can do an experiment on
either side of the equation here okay I
want you to pay both of these cars off
today and I want you to drive around and
tell somebody I'll give you $5,500 in
cash and a reputable place and see if
they'll fix your transmission right
because you've got cash and then I want
you to sleep for a
week and then if your stress
doesn't relieve a little bit if you're
not a little bit more fun to be around
or you have a little bit more joy in
your home then you can go back out and
take a loan out on these
cars and tell him John delone said you
could yes now does taking a loone make
sense like I
the world most people undervalue the
cost of what I would call a soul tax
because there's a part of your brain
always scanning the environment 247 365
trying to make sure we're safe and if
you owe somebody else money it knows one
one little glip in The Matrix one report
from one of your employees that you did
X Y or Z and it's just easier to let you
go and it knows we lose the cars and we
probably lose the house
and that little part of your brain never
shuts off and it would be failing if it
let you sleep all night because you're
not secure and so most people are like d
I'm making 6% in a highy old savings
account my interest rate is 4% so I'm
actually keeping the 2% I'll pay that 2%
for my sleep tax any day of the freaking
week you throw a mortgage on top of that
and they can't take your home away now
it's game
on see what I'm saying okay so if we the
truck problem right and we just fix it
and move on with our life what are we
what should I be doing differently
because like we maxed our 401K out for
the year awesome Can't contribute
anymore dude if I'm so that's 265 is
everything to your
name uh no there's more money havec fund
we both
have yes okay so anything beyond your
emergency fund I'm throwing it the house
let's pay these car loans off I know it
sounds crazy because let me guess you
got a low interest rate on that mortgage
yeah for sure and I made this money in
real estate and so like that is why I'm
keeping that's why I enjoy having the
cash like if something comes out I can
jump on it I would pay off your primary
home and then start dealing with
investment property with
cash I tell you that John would do the
same I would do the same Dave Ramsey has
done the same and he's amassed quite the
real estate portfolio in
cash yeah and so that's you're paying
off your first loan first and then going
exactly for cash real estate so you're
not overleveraged with so much risk you
got a mortgage hanging over your head
with your family and then you're also
hoping to make the spread on on this
investment property it's simply too much
risk and you're going to get there in no
time making 265 without a mortgage
payment simp you're going to be buying
real estate like no one's business in a
few years but right now we we can clean
up this mess real quick man tell your I
think the unfortunate thing is we have
not been budgeting like we just kind of
started and realized we were blowing
like 20 grand a month there you go the
power of a budget dude you're going to
get such a raise when you start doing a
budget yeah I mean we've already seen
the the change in one month really we
like shave all right here's the deal
we're gonna hook you up we're gonna hook
you up we're gonna give you every dollar
the best um app on the planet for
budgeting for planning for paying off
debt you and your wife can dream
together here's how quick it's going to
take us to buy another rental property
to buy this duplex we want to buy we can
begin to put all these stuff in there
and we're going to give it to it links
up to your bank so you and your wife
talk about what we're buying what we're
what like our budget that we create
together you both entered in there
together and it attaches to your bank so
you know in real time what we're buying
so we're going to hook you up stay on
the line here and we'll get you taken
care of with every dollar the greatest
budgeting app on planet I like John I
like him a lot and I like guys from
Boston because that's where I'm from
but joh it's the second call we've had
this hour where somebody's like hey uh
what I'm doing not working and I make
too much money to be this broke or I
make too much money I have too much
money in the in the bank account and I
don't have this one thing I got $200,000
in the bank and I can't pull the trigger
on a $7,000 car repair and that tells me
the person has money the person's got
intelligence they don't have peace yeah
right they don't have peace that's worth
something that means it may be worth
paying off the the lower interest rate
first even though it doesn't make
mathematical sense because it means
they'll actually get out of debt this
time and the question I think we always
have to ask oursel is what secur why do
we earn money what do what do we amass
after we pay for our Basics what does it
give us does it give us opportunity
maybe does it give us this false sense
of security maybe does it give us
opportunity to go on vacations yeah but
if it's not giving
you then you're doing it wrong you're
doing it wrong because if you if you
solve for peace then nobody cares what
you drive and nobody cares what you're
wearing the spread on the interest
doesn't matter as much does matter right
it's just about solving for peace
beautiful reminder well hey you guys can
go check out every dollar as well this
is the way to actually pay attention to
where your money's going to stop
overspending to save more and uh we've
got a lot of new features in there that
are great so go check it out you can
download it it's a free app for IOS and
Android go to everydollar.com and get
started today that puts this hour of the
ramsy show in the books my thanks to my
co-host Dr John delone all the guys in
the booth keeping their show float and
you America will be back before you know
[Music]
it
n
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions it's the ramsy show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create amazing
relationships I'm Ramsey personality
George camel joined by my esteemed
colleague Dr John deloney that's with
two phds in case you're wondering how to
spell that and uh we are here to help
you take the right next step with your
relationships with your money with your
mental health
all of it right here on the Ramsey Show
and it's totally free 8825
5225 Abe joins us first in New York City
Abe welcome to the show hey guys thanks
so much for taking my call sure how can
we help uh so I started a new job last
month and I went out and got myself a
brand new Tesla
o I'm assuming not with
cash um not with cash but I could oh all
right the plot thickens well George has
one and I want one so why don't just go
pay it off we'll all all three of us we
high
five yeah definitely um well so my
company's giving me on top of my salary
and everything else $1,000 squat each
month for car expenses so I was paying
my my commute is around an hour and a
half each way and I was driving my 2004
Honda Accord completely paid off uh but
I was consuming about $600 in gas each
month um and so I figured payments on a
new Tesla for 680 versus gas for 600 you
know pay it off pay it off it's paay it
off pay it off dude um all righty I'm
trying to save the money that I have for
a down payment on a house um and between
me and my wife we're going to come away
with around
$290,000 next uh year where's that
from um my job uh I make about 200 plus
uh 20% bonus at the end of the year
plus uh the 12,000 for a car and my wife
the teacher making in about
27,000 okay so what's your total
household income going to be you think
close to 300 290 okay yeah so that's
your total household income what are you
taking home from
that um 10,000 on my part two and a half
on her part wow is that all in taxes
where's all that money going yeah taxes
uh right now I don't have my four I'm
I'm too new for a 401k here um and
pretty much all taxes goodness gracious
I mean you're talking just 50%
gone yeah you should move to Tennessee
no state income tax okay let's talk
about this Tesla so how much money do
you have in the
bank um in my checking savings that's
stuff that's liquid I could get to any
minute I about six um I've got 10 in a
401k I've got 25 in some investing
accounts my grandfather manages that I'm
not touching till he do
and I have about 180 in uh index funds
that I manage wow okay so you love
investing that's good yeah and how old
are you I'm 27 wow and what other debt
do you have nothing just this one
Tesla yep how
much um I put nothing down so financed
about 40 um and it's going to come out
to like $8,000 in uh interest in fees by
the end of the loan in six years but if
I put the full thousand down which I
plan to do each month I'll have it paid
off in just under four years what if you
just paid it off tomorrow
Tada
um yeah I could do that and then the
Thousand just goes right back into the
account at this point the Investments
have about leveled out to where I was
about a year ago so it's no loss either
way um yeah I would cash out on uh 40K
worth of index funds and be done with it
and be as you said there's pretty much
no gains
there right and by the way I would also
take the rest of that out and I would
create an emergency fund you make too
much money to be this
broke right so in essence I have it
there as an emergency F if I need it
I'll pull it out but but it goes down
because you know what happens Abe
because you're smart enough to know this
when the Market's down it's going to
hurt to pull money out when oh crap the
HVAC hit as soon as the market took a
downturn and now I can't sell because
I'm at a loss and you're going to have
too much emotional pain to get rid of it
versus it being liquid in a savings
account 4% interest you'll be
okay all right so John's right I I'd
probably Cash Out 80 of that 180 and use
40 on the car and put 40 in an emergency
fund in a high yield savings account and
just be done with it all and what you're
here's what you're solving for that you
probably never solved for before you do
a lot of calculations in your head and
you run a lot of numbers and I don't say
this pejoratively dude I say this like
out of high respect for you also you're
27 and you've never been mashed in the
mouth
economically yeah I have and that day
will come again it's a cycle it runs it
will come again and you make too much
money to only have
$6,000 liquid to your name that you can
get your hands on at a moment's
notice right so it's only because I'm
between jobs like this past month has
been restocking on the money that I was
missing between jobs that's the only
reason it's so low when my wife and I we
do a a z budget and we have about $3,000
this month that we have no idea what to
do with you know cool put an emergency
fund well you you'll restock all the
money you're investing and whatever your
next your down payment goal you're going
to free that up with freeing up this car
payment number one and having money in
the bank already then all the rest of
the money can go towards investing
saving the down payment and you can
choose your own adventure with how
aggressive you want to get with the down
payment versus
investing we're going to pay a we're
going to pay a tiny percentage in Soul
tax which is I get to sleep knowing I I
have cash that I can get to and get out
of here if I need to or I can fix
something if I need to I got a car
that's 1,000% mine nobody owes because
here's a deal you're working in like
this 20% this 20% bonus I've got some
friends who work on a they get paid at
the bottom deal and it has been very
lucrative and they've gone through a
couple of years where it has been a
nightmare true just because the business
decides to invest instead of doing X or
they're moving this around or we're
recoup this over here it just gets messy
and so I want to I would love you to
have a pile of cash that you can sleep
on and a car that's yours and then you
buy a house with cash yall just make too
much money it's going to be dope dude
you're going to be set yourself up but
you're going to be doing this in a
healthy way not a what about this what
about this move this over here oh gosh
this is down and so on and so
forth but but we both love Teslas so
good for you yeah out of uh curiosity a
which one did you get was a model 3 long
range no no got the base model 3 I was
not spending any more money on any of
the non-necessary stuff I just needed a
car that could drive me to in from work
and that's it you know wow that cost 40
Grand yeah New York dude it's the New
York tax I guess
wow well enjoy it man you you make
enough money federal tax credit so
that's tax credits John oh yeah that
every wealthy people I've interview they
all went man it's the the tax I got rich
on tax credits in in Airplane miles push
this over the edge that's got rich hey
um here's the deal if you uh when the
time comes and it sounds like it's
getting there very quickly um go to
ramseys solutions.com and look up um
real estate agents okay and when you
move to Tennessee or Texas or wherever
you're going to move to that doesn't
have a state income tax you're getting
get out of that Madness you get to keep
80 or 90% of your check instead of 50
then um you'll get to change your
fortune forever reach but Abe I'm proud
of you man you're crushing it at 27
great job and we want you to be
unbelievably wealthy and have no traps
and distractions along the way and that
means no car loans no credit cards no
student loans no personal loans and uh
you're going to be a homeowner soon and
you're going to pay off a mortgage real
quick if you just stay focused on one
thing at a time and don't let lifestyle
creep into your life where you have
$150,000 in expenses every year because
you can live on less than you make man
that is the key to Building Wealth this
is the ramsy
show
[Music]
he
welcome back to the Ramy show I'm George
Campell joined by Dr John deloney let's
get to the phone Zach joins us up next
in Tallahassee Zach what's going
on hey how are you guys doing well how
are you I'm doing good um I have
hopefully not a stupid question um no
stupid questions only stupid answers and
they come from
John oh yes sir yes sir yes sir um I'm
26 and I I currently work as a a music
teacher teach band in Elementary music
my fiance is a general manager at a
restaurant and so I uh I'm looking at
the Florida retirement system and I I'd
love I'm grateful for the perk but when
I'm looking at it long term it's just
peanuts and financially right now I feel
stuck and a bit clueless and maybe it's
for my own agent inexperience I really
don't know what to do because I'm
looking at my bank account and after
watching watching the Dave Ramsey Show
and hearing what all the people are
making at my age and what I'm doing
right now I I love what I'm doing I just
I feel stuck how I'm worried that I'm 26
all right um I have this I have an
experience so I was 21 and it was my
first High School teaching job at a
giant public school and I was a coach
and I loved every second of that job
every second of it I like my colleagues
I like my my fellow coaches I like the
athletes I love my students I loved all
of it and I'll never forget after my
first year teaching going into my second
they handed me a spreadsheet or like a
piece of paper but it had it it was it
was basically a spreadsheet they'd print
it out like a table and I could just
find out what age and how much money I'd
be
making and I remember thinking yeah and
that's the salary schedule and I'm I am
aware of that no but but I remember I
remember looking at that and thinking oh
I'm
out like oh yeah I remember thinking I
want there to be some variability I want
the opportunity to go earn like I want
to be able to win and not just on
sporting field but I want to be able to
go do good in the world and help people
solve problems and and also uh make a
good income I can provide for my family
so I've been exactly where you are I'm
looking around going where's where's all
this where's all this Economic Security
right and you're doing a really really
really hard job hard
job yeah I just I I'm very passionate
about uh teaching band the one thing
that I know and love yeah you're real
life School of Rock right now and I'm
I'm just I'm jealous a little bit George
is still stuck in the Tata T so he'll
get there he'll get there well from two
musicians we're thankful for uh teachers
like you who are out there inspiring the
Next
Generation Lord knows I'm trying my best
and I love it but man
like pay I'm grateful for it but it's
it's penut well let's talk about what
this future could look like so what's
your current
salary I'm make 42 and a half a year
okay and what and you're you're not
married you have a fiance any plans to
get yeah married or is it still we're
getting married in June exciting okay do
you know what your household income
would be by then combined income we're
roughly looking at between the both of
us were're roughly looking at 90 awesome
okay so that's the near future you know
a dual income makes a huge difference as
far as Building
Wealth yeah and what are your retirement
options right now what's it look like is
it M I'm at the FRS um it's something I
can't withdraw without penalty until I'm
65 right now they take about
$127 out of my paycheck a month and
that's Curr and this is my third year of
teaching and I'm currently standing at
roughly 9,000 but I can't touch it until
I retire at 65 but it's when you're 65
and they'll probably move it to 70 by
the time you get there but are are they
gonna average your top three years and
that's going to pay you a percentage of
that it's just going to keep growing and
then whatever it's at I just withdraw
from is it essentially like a 401k or is
it more like a pension I think that's
what John's getting
at oh I'm sorry my again I'm
inexperience and I'm sorry uh my teacher
retirement when I was in the state and
I've been at the state as a university
professor and as a public school teacher
it was they take your three highest
years or five highest years average that
together and then I get a percentage of
that like 70% of that number okay okay
all right so it's very similar to that
yeah so you do have other options one of
those options is a Roth IRA and I would
encourage you to start that
today so the way Roth IRA yeah write
that down and we've got tons of
resources on our site and we have a
there's a program called smartvestor and
you can connect with investment Pros all
over the country through our website at
Ramy solutions.com that can help with
this to walk you through it but this is
essentially a retirement plan that's not
connected to your employer and you have
full control on what to invest in there
and I've got a whole YouTube video on
Investing For Beginners that I encourage
you to go watch on my YouTube channel
Channel and the simple strategy I lay
out is match beats Roth beats
traditional so if you have a match
through your employer let's start there
then we're going to move to all the Roth
options for you that may just be the
Roth IRA for now and you can Max that
out and then you can move to the
traditional
side and then how do you feel about a
403b yeah those are great I mean that's
essentially like the 401K for you and I
like that because you have more control
uh versus this pension and so are you a
debt free right now something you would
run I'm sorry are you debt
free I have 9,000 in student loans and
that's it okay well I would be tackling
the debt aggressively so that we can get
back to investing because right now
there's a certain uh process that I want
you to follow it's called the Ramsey
Baby Steps where you attack all the
Consumer Debt first meaning we're going
to use our savings do you have any money
in the bank to throw at this student
loan debt so uh I have about 1,200 in my
bank account after paying bills uh and
and then uh the only other thing that I
own that's of value is I have an
instrument worth about 8,000 and my car
is paid off with no debt and that's
worth about 30 wow I'm curious about
this instrument what is it it's a tuba
is it a Sentimental
tuba
uh uh I half of me wants to say yes okay
I'm just wondering that looks a whole
lot like debt Freedom yeah getting rid
of that tuo but that's probably
collecting dust cuz I'm guessing if it's
$88,000 you don't want to use it much no
I use it uh it's for my side hustles so
because to supplement my income I work
uh I don't I don't take days off uh I
haven't had a day off in a long time I
work at a butcher shop and then I use
that instrument to teach lessons which
pays me 40 an hour and at the butcher
shop I take home it's under the table of
probably around uh $100 every time I
show up what is a what's a used tuba
cost these days so like if you're look
so they come in beginner models
professional and intermediate models
range uh typically you'll see
professional grade tubas that range from
5 grand all the way up to
30 but what about used could you go
used uh yeah I mean my tuba is used in
it's worth right now at around 8,000 I'm
just wondering can we offload the tuba
get out of debt and then cash flow the
next one to keep the side hustle going
it's just an option it's just one option
to get you out of debt faster so that
you can get to investing which is
something that you want to do but when
you think about this you can go crunch
the numbers on our investment calculator
at ramsy solutions.com from 26 to 66 you
have 40 years to
invest and so that gives me a lot of uh
hope and confidence that you're going to
retire a millionaire and that's not
withstanding your fiance's income as you
guys get married and combined finances
and you guys will both be making a great
income over the years knocking it up to
six figures and you're going to increase
investing at that point as well as your
income goes up that 15% gets bigger and
bigger and also call me silly would it
be worth consider because the I've
actually had more thoughts on selling
off the card than I have my own
instrument that sounds stupid no I mean
$30,000 is a lot of money um based on
what you probably bring home and salary
so I wouldn't have any problem if you
sold a $30,000 car and bought $15,000
car and took that 15 grand and paid off
your debt that's a great move I think
very
wise okay um here's the other thing any
advice on selling custom Vehicles custom
how custom are we talking yeah it's a
did you build this thing in the garage
Dodge Challenger and I've modified it to
all hell did you didn't get it lowered
Too Fast Too Furious Tokyo Drift did you
custom rims custom speakers custom
engine parts all the works and
everything but I have no payments on it
I bought the thing in toll it was from
the whole GameStop Escapade and I on an
Impulse that I regret I sold I when I
made a lot of money off the gamees I
spent all that stupid car and I love the
thing but does it go like this does it
get a pretty good impression Dave Ramy
would call that uh up Dave would call
that your stupid tax that's what you get
yeah only when you wind it up it makes
that sound oh boy gosh I know it starts
you have to pull a rope to start it good
job dude there's there you know what
just like nfts and crypto there's always
another sucker that might buy it so I'd
go ahead and post it and uh hope for the
best my friend but I have faith you'll
be out of debt soon you'll retire a baby
steps millionaire you just got to follow
the proven plan my friend thanks for the
call this is the ramsy
[Music]
show
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George camel joined by Dr John
delone let me tell you right now if you
like this show please help us out
consider subscribing leaving review
sharing it with a friend all of that
matters we don't have a big giant
marketing budget we're not you know
sponsoring uh stadiums we're just out
here doing our best to help people and
you guys are the marketing you just
telling people how this show has
impacted you uh how it's changed your
life the entertainment value you get
from it when Jon is on all of that
matters so continue to do that it would
mean the world to us Britney joins us up
next in Sacramento Britney welcome to
the ramsy
show hi guys thanks so much much for
taking my call I met you both at the
Smart conference in April and it was
amazing
awesome so calling about I got into a
very small accident in September it's
just like front bumper damag and I hurt
my left arm but it's not a huge deal the
insurance agent just called me on
Saturday and started offering you know
here's some money that we're going to
give you for pain and suffering but also
we're going to give you money for
medical when she found out that my two
children were in the car with me she
started saying oh well were they injured
and I said no they were on the opposite
side of the vehicle you know they're
okay and she saidwell we want to give
them something too so she said normally
they start out at like $500 per kid but
because we've waited eight weeks to even
hear from this insurance company she's
like I'm going to give you the max which
is 2500 per child and they're 14 and 11
my son and my daughter um and we have
five kids and we're on baby step two so
when the lady was like you can use this
money for them or you can use this money
for you guys it's really up to your
discretion and I thought oh well I don't
know what we should do so I thought
about calling you guys because I follow
you we do every doll
we've done fbu and we're um working hard
on baby step too but we have a kind of a
long way to go another couple years so
we just weren't sure should I be putting
the $2,500 per kid into an account for
them when they're older or if because
you know they don't care honestly about
the accident they were like they looked
up from their phone and they're like
what just happened oh nothing and they
weren't affected so to speak I mean I'm
just trying to find out what's ethically
right and what I should do to really
just I think you should call that agent
back and ask for a million
dollars yeah that would be nice that's
the strangest Insurance call I I mean
I've had people with like cancer broken
legs and the insurance is like nope nope
nope nope and they're trying to find
ways to give you money previous yeah and
this one is the first nicest insurance
agent I've ever worked with in my life
I'm not kidding and she very helpful and
she was just like I'm so so sorry and I
can't believe how this has affected you
and your family and all this stuff and I
was like wow this is a nicest insurance
age have ever talked
to wow did you have to sign something
that says no matter what you'll never
come back and ask for anything more as
long as you live nope nope they get they
sent me emails for both children saying
if they have any Growing Pains or in
Insurance problems later that they can
come back until they're 20 years old and
sue them for any money they'd like oh my
goodness dude I you just gave me a hope
I was just telling George during the
break like I think we're all doomed and
you just turned it around with one call
I know it's absolutely crazy but wow it
was like I said
unicorn okay so your question really is
about more what do I do with this money
technically it was for the kids but we
have debt to pay
off yeah so200 a p that's $5,000 that's
a huge amount and like we've been
working really hard I'm a nurse I work
night shift which my husband hates but
we're like until we get out of baby 2
I'm GNA work really hard I'm G stay on
night for the next two three years and
you know it's an extra $30,000 a year to
stay on night shift ah and um the kid
you know we working hard but we like
saved up um cash in August and I worked
four extra shifts so I could bring home
$2500 to pay for our daughter's braces
outright so we wouldn't get another
payment you know so we're trying really
hard to make sure we don't go into any
more debt but we're taking care of
things for the kids and stuff like that
so it's like I'm not saying we should
use the money at all I'm just saying I
don't know what the right thing is
because with compound interest what is
2500 for Jackson when he's you know 18
versus 14 or for when he's 25 I don't
know we have like I said we have five
kids we have two about to go to college
right now so we're like oh what life is
expensive I think the greatest gift you
can give your kids and George told me if
I'm wrong I think the greatest gift you
can give your kids is a mom and dad that
can
breathe and a mom and dad that
um have peace so they can deal with the
regular crap that's the rest of our life
and a mom that finally gets to stop
working the night shift because she's
she's just worked her butt off trying to
get this stuff taken care of and so I'd
throw that money on your debt and just
use it as money from above and just stop
somebody in a conversation in the future
if they ever badmouth an insurance agent
say no I met a good one once she's
amazing she was good and in addition to
the money for the kids she's also saying
that they're double-checking if they can
make it more but they're trying to offer
me like seven to 10,000 just for the
fact that I missed a night of work and
I'm like doing doctor yeah so that's an
addition to the medical cost I think
John's spot on here Britney so what's
your total debt load what's left ah
289,000 not including our house whoa is
that a lot of student loans that is
everything except cars we have no car
payments we paid off our cars during
coid uh and we've been working we have
two time shares that I'm in the process
of getting out of we have student loans
we have credit cards we have a personal
loan and we have a solar loan on our
house oh boy so and our house we this is
something my husband and I have talked
about many times but our house is worth
1.5 million we're in California and we
could sell and pay off everything but I
kept telling them that's an easy fix I
don't want to you know not steal this I
want to make sure that we're doing hard
work you know following all the steps
and try to make sure we're doing the
best we can what's your household income
this is 260,000 oh wonderful what does
he do for a living He installs water
heaters what do you do I'm a night shift
nurse I work in the ICU and the
emergency department so did you go get
your doctorate or something uh I have a
MERS but I paid my MERS in cash actually
uh so the student loan that's left I
think it's about 880,000 in student
loans that's um all from my bachelor's
degree
cuz I was went through a really bad
divorce in like 2014 and so we're a
blended family now and like so we have a
really good you know income but we have
our solar loan is 60,000 so a lot of
that is student loans solar and then the
rest is all jumbled of credit cards and
personal loans and all that okay so the
good news is you have a great income I'm
going to yes go through the baby steps
one by one smallest to largest start
knocking these out and making 260 if you
keep this up how quickly do you guys
plan on paying off this 289 in debt um
we calculated probably about 24 months
and the only reason I say yeah I think
24 months because of you know in cost
that have been incurred I swear every
month something happens right now we've
had car repairs we've had my brother
ended up going into the hospital and I
had to help him like there's just like
all these little things that have
happened where we just $1,000 here and,
here which we've all cash flow now but
we started the plan again since I um uh
been with you guys in April at the Smart
conference so starting in July we just
have tackled and I've made I don't even
know I think we've paid off already
let's see debt payoff we've already paid
off 24,000 awesome awesome will you make
me a
promise yes that you will not borrow
money for your kids to go to college
when they leave next year oh absolutely
not we have debt free degree we have
they have scholarships we already have
six colleges that have accepted my
daughter with scholarship offers we are
not doing any debt absolutely awesome
awesome awesome we are on board with
that Mom of the year right there thank
you so much for the call Britney wow w
that's a lot of debt John with a great
income but even in California that
income can disappear very quickly so we
say don't do this a lot George but part
of me
thinks if you're sitting on $1.5 million
and you got the message and you've
learned it I get the I want to feel it
and we need deduce Behavior change that
you get a Britney who's like no I want
to change my behavior I don't want the
shortcut to get out of debt but almost
it feels like I want to be fogged for
this for this as we go instead of no
we're going to we got two kids leaving
for school we're going to downsize a
little bit we're going to go from 1.5 to
$1 million house we pay everything off
that's pretty wild how I consider that
1.5 to 1.2 clears the debt completely
tomorrow wipes it out uh so that is
something I would consider especially as
the kids head off to college I like that
game plan and somebody tells me hey I
went through a traumatic divorce I had
undergrad stuff I've got this and we
gosh we've just done dumb after dumb and
never again I don't know part of me says
man if y'all can come together and sell
that house that'd be cool well what's
amazing is when you think about the fact
that people people as they enter their
adult life start accumulating debt this
might be the first time in her life they
become debt-free with no payments in the
world in their adult life no question
and I think people they don't really
take time to Grapple with what that
would feel like mentally emotionally
physically on their bodies to owe no one
anything for the first time in their
adult life cuz they're so used to it
right or they take out a $60,000 solar
loan which I'm a huge fan of I'm going
to get solar in my place but so they
don't have to pay $300 a month bill
right oh yeah we can justify all day
long with math and that's when the train
goes off the tracks at justification
station every time John did you just
rhyme H call that was painful I'm no
Eminem but I get the job done no you you
are not you're a Skittle this is the
Ramsay
[Music]
[Applause]
show
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsay show our
scripture of the day comes from Matthew
6 20 and 21 store up for yourselves
Treasures in Heaven where moths and
Vermin do not destroy and where thieves
do not break in and steal for where your
treasure is there your heart will be
also Paul Stanley from one of John's
favorite bands kiss there it is said
this charity is not an option it is an
obligation that was not on my bingo card
and I quote I want a rock and roll all
night and party every day we should have
chosen that quote I think it's just as
powerful disagree okay fair enough well
let's get to the phones Joanne awaits in
Jacksonville Joanne what's what's going
on with
you hi um John and George I just want to
thank you guys for taking my call today
sure how can we help so yeah so
essentially we're I'm wanting your
thoughts on whether or not we should
sell our property um our situation is my
husband is active duty military he's
been U military for 22 years
and um pretty much 22 years ago his
parents helped him to buy a home a piece
of property um and we've since paid it
off so we own it um free and clear we're
also completely out of debt we have been
for um gosh probably almost 10 years now
wow um but we're wondering if we should
sell it to buy another home or if we
should just buy another home where we
are um we think we'll be here in this
location for another five or six
years um and we do have $100,000 saved
up as a down payment and where we've
paused um retirement to stack up more
cash for you know all the fees and
things um we do rent our property um
it's in Washington state we rent it and
uh we get about after paying the
property manager we get about 1,300 a
month um from that and our I reached out
to our property manager and asked her um
what it would be worth if we to sell it
um my husband initially bought it for I
think 64,000 and she said it's worth
over $500,000 now wow that's
amazing okay so let's say you sell it
and you get 500,000 plus your 100,000
you want to pay cash for a spot in
Jacksonville for
600,000 well see that's the problem
we've never lived there so we'd have to
pay Capital
Gains plus all the other I think it
would increase our tax bracket by having
all that earned income it definitely we
lose we'd lose 20% out the gig right
with capital
gains and then how much more would we
have to pay in in taxes I don't know but
George you're the smart one here but I
thought if you roll it immediately into
another property you don't pay capital
gain with a 1031 exchange right well
this would be that would be investment
property but you're wanting a primary
home
right but it has never been our primary
home so from what I understand the law
is you have to have lived in it for the
last two years and they do bend the
rules a little for the military yeah to
avoid up to $500,000 of gain yeah yeah
so you would have to pay the capital
gains on that yeah I don't think we
could get out of that and it would be
that 20% tax rate according to my
estimations yeah yeah but let's also say
this so the house is appreciated a
significant amount
so if they had called and they had the
manager had told you hey it's worth
400,000 or 425,000
would you guys still have jumped up and
down and
celebrated I think so I mean gosh it's
it's appreciated so much I just wonder
do we want to lose that much in taxes
when there is a chance right when he
retires we could go live there for a
couple years and then not have to pay
that when we sell
it but there's no guarantee that we'll
go live there that's exactly right and
so there's this weird phenomenon and I I
slip my mind right now it's late in the
afternoon it's a it's a it's a
psychological way of minds work right
and it's a psychological mind way our
minds worked that was a terrible
sentence brilliant this is why they pay
this guy the Big Buck if somebody says
hey um um you got $5 coming to you and
then later that afternoon someone goes
dude I was way off you're getting $150
and then when you get the check you open
it it says hundred bucks in it and you
say I thought I was get 150 they're like
yeah dude the calculations were all over
the place today but dude you get a 100
bucks that's 95 more dollars than you
thought you were going to get yet your
your body goes oh dude I lost 50
bucks
right you gain 95 more than you were
expecting yet it feels like a loss
because that other number was out there
and so part of me says do what's best
for your like part of selling
transacting real estate unless somebody
knows something different than I do
George is paying taxes on what you buy
and what you sell that's part of life
what's best for your family right
now might not be to have a would you buy
a $500,000 property in Washington to
make 1,300 bucks on it every month
living in Jacksonville no right normally
no right and so part of me says man take
it take the take your 375 that you would
get plus your 100 and get yourself a
spot in Jacksonville and you'll be okay
missing out on the 15 grand a year in
rental income that just feels like such
a win to me a win to the pieace like of
your
household and even if you take on a
small mortgage you're not violating any
of the principles get a 15year fix where
the payment's no more than a quarter of
your take home pay and uh that's how you
know you're not biting off more than you
can chew and you'll still be able to pay
that off really quickly cuz I want you
guys debt free again real soon so if you
can't pay cash for a place at least roll
all of that into it so you have all of
that Equity with a real small mortgage
which is also going to lower your
monthly payment which also allows you to
pay it off real
fast right that's what John and I would
do if we were in your
shoes all right thank you guys so much
absolutely and thank your husband for uh
his service active duty 22 years that's
absolutely awesome impressive and a lot
of sacrifice goes into that with all the
moves every few years and uh we
appreciate that does not go unnoticed
Dylan joins us in Columbia Missouri
Dylan welcome to the ramsy show how you
doing good how are you got to Dad how
are you guys good we're hanging in
you're the last question of the day so
you better bring a hot one for us what's
up right so uh I've been trying to get
through for a while with my work
schedule I haven't been able to get
through but with my work schedule
changing I've been able to get through
um so I'm blessed to be able to do that
so uh we started working on uh the Ramy
program about eight months ago um we're
on baby sub number two um we have
knocked down our debt pretty
significantly we started about
46,000 um with uh some uh two vehicles
and then some personal debt that we had
um we're down to uh just the vehicles
and then a couple about 3,000 left on
medical and other little individual
things with the uh baby steps or with
the um the snowball
um so we are we'll in the next month
we'll have that um 30,000 or so paid off
um and that'll leave our two vehicles um
we owe roughly about um 13 to
15,000 each on those um we have
attempted to try and sell um one of them
which is a 2016 Ford Explorer um I have
a 2017 Ford
F-150 um and we've attempted to try and
sell the explore um I haven't had any
luck um we've posted it we've got a
couple people interest um what's your
household
income um so um single income my wife
stays at home with the kids um so our
household income um is roughly
about 3,000 a
month man yeah one of these cars has to
go that's a lot of car for making 36
Grand a year
yeah well and that's with and that's
with or $3,000 a paycheck sorry not a
month $3,000 paycheck that gives me a
lot more peace I was like man okay
what's the Explorer worth you think um
so it's roughly um when we KY blue
booket right around 16 to 18 okay and
then what would you do without that car
uh that's the the thing that we will
have to get U so I drive about an hour
two two an hour back for work every day
um I work in Jefferson City um so we
would have to uh get a just a car to
drive back and forth um which that's
what we'd like to use be difference than
what we owe well you're going need maybe
a little bit more than that cuz I don't
want you in car repairs cuz you got a
hoopie and said George made me do it so
save up a little bit of money get
something reliable maybe five or six
grand and then you can sell it get that
other car uh with cash that's the move
man you'll get there either way it might
take some side houses and sacrifice but
I hope you get that car sold soon that
puts this hour of the ramsy show in the
books until next time spend wisely save
intentionally and give
[Music]
generously